Let's read this storybook. Can you find a bear?
Yes, Dad. Look at this! A bear goes into the tunnel.
Then, can you find boys?
I see a boy coming out of the tunnel.
And there is another boy that goes through the forest.
Where are rabbits? Can you find them?
Yes, I see a rabbit that goes over the hill.
Good. And I see another one that goes around the corner!
Roads, roads, roads, roads go everywhere.
I see a road going around corners, and it winds around.
Roads go through the country, and they go to big cities.
I see a road going up and down the hill like a roller coaster.
Roads go over mountains, and they go through forests.
I see a road going into and coming out of the tunnel.
Roads cross over rivers, and they are on bridges.
I see a road that just stops. Wow, it is a dead end.